pour accueillir maintenant un autre
invité retour à la politique exige de
bertrand cazeneuve qui est le président
des jeunes radicaux de gauche alors des
jeunes radicaux de gauche qui vont avoir
du pain sur la planche en ce mois de mai
et surtout au mois de juin puisque la
fin juin il y aura un congrès national
de ce mouvement free vient de voir le
jour il ya peu dans notre région oui oui
le mouvement des jeunes radicaux de
gauche est né en gironde le 26 janvier
1983 c'est donc un jeune mouvement à
jeanne mouvement qui a beaucoup
d'ambition pour ce département je les
dis à mater les entreprises encore
samedi au congrès du mouvement des
jeunes des radicaux de gauche qui se
tenait à saint médard en jalles nous
avons la volonté de rendre le
radicalisme à la gironde et cette
volonté il faut se donner l'amour les
moyens de la réaliser
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons mener un certain nombre de
manifestations qui vont permettre aux
jeunes radicaux de gauche d'affirmer
leurs positions avec toujours plus de
force dans notre département
alors l'heure le légalisme pour vous de
me le définissez vous le radicalisme
c'est l'affirmation de la volonté de
l'homme d'influer sur son destin il y a
deux courants à gauche le courant
marxiste et le courant humaniste nous
appartenons nous premier courant le
courant humaniste c'est à dire que nous
considérons qu'il n'y a aucune fatalité
qui s'impose à l'homme c'est sa
conscience qui influe sur sa manière
d'être social et non la verse
c'est à dire que l'homme par la volonté
de ses idées à la possibilité d'influer
sur le destin politique de son pays et
je reprendrai la formule d'un historien
radical connu albert thibaudet qui
disait justement que la politique se
sont décidés
comment voyez-vous le relevé des jeunes
de votre mouvement dans la politique
actuelle je crois que les jeunes
mouvement se fixe généralement pour
objectif de répondre aux aspirations des
jeunes c'est à dire qu'il se préoccupe
essentiellement des problèmes qui
touchent la jeunesse ce que nous faisons
mais nous pensons au delà de ces simples
préoccupations qu'il faut pour nous
préparer l'avenir et dépassé ce stade de
deux problèmes qui concernent la
jeunesse pour essayer de construire une
société qui dans le futur permettront à
la jeunesse actuelle de vivre mieux car
je crois qu'il y a un grand malaise ou
aujourd'hui parmi les jeunes les
mouvements dont vous parlez
régulièrement au moment de vos journaux
télévisés en sont la preuve évidente
alors les jeunes les biens les jeunes il
s'agit aussi ils ont des problèmes dans
les facultés alors comment vous les
jeunes vous percevez cette invitation
vous me posez une question extrêmement
difficile compte tenu du fait mais je
vais y répondre
compte tenu du fait que le mouvement des
jeunes radicaux de gauche n'est pas un
syndicat étudiant
et ce sont les uns des syndicats
étudiants qui ont à se prononcer sur ce
type de problème je peux néanmoins vous
dire mon sentiment personnel je crois
qu'effectivement cette loi à certains
aspects qui ne sont peut-être pas tout à
fait positif qu'elle mériterait
certainement d'être amendé mais il faut
bien se dire que ce n'est pas par une
action violente et parfois excessives
comme nous avons pu la constater jusqu'à
aujourd'hui que nous y arriverons je
crois qu'il faut garder son calme de
toutes parts il faut que le ministère de
l'éducation ouvre ses portes et que les
étudiants acceptent de franchir des
portes ouvertes de manière à négocier la
négociation est une arme prioritaire en
démocratie constitutionnelle
oui vous auriez employé le même langage
en 68 or tout à fait je crois que les
moves les syndicats de gauche mènerait
aujourd'hui ce type d'action je serai
tout aussi hostile alors pour en revenir
à votre mouvement il va y avoir en
attendant le congrès national du hadj et
juin une série de manifestations locales
départementales oui toute une série de
manifestations locales sur des thèmes
généraux qui vont nous permettre de
présenter nos idées mais aussi une série
de manifestations sur des thèmes
spécialisés nous aurons au bouscat dans
deux semaines une réunion sur un thème
général qui nous permettra de présenter
un certain nombre de nos idées qui de
réunion qui devrait se tenir je crois
dans la deuxième semaine de mai nous
avons une réunion qui se tiendra très
certainement à bègles au mois de juin
qui portera sur l'avenir de la médecine
et qui sera présentée par le responsable
de notre commission médecine et puis
nous avons ce grand congrès du 26 juin
que nous préparons avec beaucoup
d'attention parce qu'il devrait nous
permettre de faire passer un certain
nombre de textes intéressants
bernard cazeneuve merci les rendez vous
sont pris nos plus grands tous ces
travaux avec intérêt